February 2015 marked the first time many
in the West heard of the cops, the
indigenous Christian inhabitants of
Egypt. That was when the Islamic State
released a video that went viral. A
gruesome scene showing jihadis brutally
beheading 20 cops and one African by the
Libyan shore. Their crime, refusing to
renounce Christ for Islam. But what is
less known is that long before the
Islamic State targeted and unwittingly
popularized the cops, countless other
Muslims in modern Egypt had persecuted
or at least discriminated against this
Christian minority. Individuals, mobs,
shakes, organizations like the Muslim
Brotherhood and the Salafi Front and
even government authorities were and
continue to be involved. In the West,
this oppression is often dismissed as an
aberration. After all, haven't Muslims
and Christians lived side by side
peacefully for centuries in Egypt? And
isn't the fact that cops still make up
12 to 15% of Egypt's population proof of
tolerance, a Muslim willingness to live
and let live for 14 centuries? These
observations, which frequently arise
when discussing the so-called Coptic
question, suggest that current conflicts
stem from temporal issues, poverty,
ignorance, tribalism, anything but
religion. The problem, however, is that
these observations rest on a faulty
premise. And false premises, as always,
lead to false conclusions. In short,
they're built on a pseudo history or a
false history or a fake history that has
long shaped the West's understanding of
Islam's relationship with non-Muslims. A
corrective is badly needed. Enter the
book in my hands, A Sword Over the Nile.
Now, a much shorter version was
originally written in Arabic. Here it
is. And after reading it several years
ago, I found its contents so valuable
that I urged its author Adel Gindi to
translate it into English. And he did,
not only providing access for English
readers, but also greatly expanding the
original Arabic work, linking it to our
present time and adding several helpful
appendixes. A sword over the Nile traces
the history of the Coptic people under
Islam from the 7th century Arab conquest
of Egypt right up until the present.
Much of it is a chronological
translation of lengthy excerpts from the
comprehensive history of the patriarchs
of the Egyptian church as well as other
Coptic primary sources, some translated
for the first time. Though the history
of the patriarchs was first translated
into English in the early 20th century,
most editions are out of print and those
that remain are quite expensive. Gindi
has not only delivered a fresh,
accessible translation, but also spared
readers the burden of waiting through
hundreds of pages of often dry,
irrelevant material to extract the most
relevant passages. The merits of this
book are many. Unlike the dominant
Muslim historiographical tradition which
tends to be heographical, putting a
saintly veneer on Muslim conduct towards
non-Muslims, the Coptic sources used in
this book are generally more accurate.
For instance, the earliest Muslim
history of the Arab conquest of Egypt
was written two centuries after the
events by Abdakam who died in 870. By
contrast, Coptic sources are
contemporaneous with the events they
recount, lending their narrative greater
authority. Moreover, by relying heavily
on Coptic sources, the book presents
Egyptian Christianity under Islam from
the perspective of the vanquished, not
the victors, who have traditionally
controlled the narrative. 400 pages of
translated source documents make it
clear that everything Egypt's cops
endure today. The burning and bombing of
their churches, the intermittent violent
persecution, the abduction and forced
conversion of Coptic girls and women,
and the entrenched social discrimination
was habitually experienced by their
ancestors over the course of some 14
centuries. The continuity is staggering.
Think of what the Islamic State did to
Christians and others except stretched
over centuries often on an exponential
scale. For example, under the Mamluks
and the persecutors, not fringe radical
Muslims, but often the very rulers of
Egypt, be they Arabs, Fatimids, Kurds,
Mluks, Turks, or of course Egyptians.
This is often confirmed by Muslim
sources. Take for example Taki Alin
al-Makzi who died in 1442. His
authoritative history of Egypt offers
anecdote after anecdote of Muslims
burning churches, slaughtering
Christians, and enslaving Coptic women
and children, quite often with the
compliance or outright cooperation of
the authorities. The only escape then,
as sometimes today, was for Christians
to convert to Islam. after describing
one particularly egregious persecution
in the 11th century when according to
al-maki some 30,000 churches were
destroyed or converted into mosques
under hakimah the fatim khalif a
staggering number that underscores just
how Christian Egypt and the middle east
were. He makes a telling observation.
Under these circumstances, he writes, a
great many Christians became Muslims.
Allahbar.
This leads to a crucial question that a
Sword Over the Niles chronological
approach clarifies. How and why did
Egypt go from being overwhelmingly
Christian in the 7th century to being
overwhelmingly Muslim in the 21st
century? To appreciate this and because
few in the west grasp just how
profoundly Christian pre-Islamic Egypt
was, consider before Islam's invasion in
the 7th century, Egypt was home to some
of Christendom's earliest theological
giants and church fathers, including
Clement of Alexandria, born in 150,
Origin the Great, born in 184, Anthony
the Great, father of monasticism, born
in 251, and Athanasios of Alexandria
born in 297. The latter being the chief
defender of the Nyian creed which is
still professed by all major Christian
denominations today. The most important
ecclesiastical and learning center of
all of ancient Christian was located in
Alexandria. Around the year 400 AD. John
Cassian, a European pilgrim, observed
how deeply Christian Egypt was. He
wrote, quote, "The traveler from
Alexandria in the north to Luxor in the
south would have in his ears along the
whole journey the sounds of prayers and
hymns of the monks scattered in the
desert. from the monasteries and from
the caves from monks, hermits and
anchorites. Some Europeans like British
historian and archaeologist Stanley Lane
P who died around 1931 even claimed
Coptic missionaries were the first to
bring the gospel to distant European
regions such as Switzerland, Britain,
and especially Ireland. Egypt has also
yielded both one of the earliest known
gospel manuscripts papyrus 52 dating to
the early 2nd century and one of the
oldest known images of Christ a 6th
century Coptic fresco from Elbahessa in
short something dramatic and cataclysmic
violent persecution as documented
clearly in the Coptic sources translated
in a sword over the Nile was responsible
for transforming Christian Egypt into
Muslim Egypt yet violence alone does not
tell the whole story the dimma system
Islam's discriminator legal framework
for governing Christian and Jewish
subjects based largely on Quran 9:29 as
well as the so-called conditions or
stipulations of Omar while providing
some religious freedom imposed fiscal
burdens such as the Jizia attacks social
inequality and a host of other
disabilities. Decade after decade,
century after century, this mounting
pressure pushed more and more Coptic
Christians to convert to Islam, easing
their burdens and granting them some
semblance of equality. In his book, The
Arab Conquest of Egypt, a great book by
the way, as it was written in 1902
before the era of political correctness
and fake history, historian Alfred
Butler wrote about this quote vicious
system of bribing the Christians into
conversion. Here's a telling excerpt. He
writes, quote, "Although religious
freedom was in theory secured for the
cops under the capitulation when they
gave in to the Arabs around 640 AD, it
soon proved in fact to be shadowy and
elucery. For a religious freedom which
became identified with social bondage
and with financial bondage could have
neither substance nor vitality. As Islam
spread, the social pressure upon the
cops became enormous, while the
financial pressure at least seemed
harder to resist. As the number of
Christians or Jews who were liable for
the pole tax, the Jiza tax diminished
year by year and their isolation be
became more conspicuous, the burdens of
the Christians grew heavier in
proportion as their numbers lessened.
That is, the more Christians converted
to Islam, the more the burdens on the
remaining few grew. The wonder,
therefore, is not that so many cops
yielded to the current which bore them
with sweeping force over to Islam, but
that so great a multitude of Christians
stood firmly against the stream, nor
have all the storms of 13 centuries
moved their faith from the rock of its
foundation. Such is the forgotten
history of how the cops went from being
the majority to being the minority of
Egypt. That 12 to 15% of Egypt is still
Christian today is not a testament to
Muslim tolerance, but rather
intolerance. While many Christian lives
were extinguished through centuries of
violence, even more spiritual and
cultural identities were erased through
conversion to Islam. There's also that
overlooked tragic irony, or rather
cycle. Those Muslims who persecute
Christians today are themselves often
descendants of cops who first embraced
Islam to escape the persecution. In
other words, if not for the stubborn
resilience and endurance of the cops,
Christianity would have been wiped out
altogether from Egypt, just as it was in
the rest of North Africa, which before
the Islamic conquest of the 7th century
was also thoroughly Christian.
Incidentally, here's a fun fact. The
Convention on the Prevention and
Punishment of the Crime of Genocide,
adopted by the UN General Assembly in
1948, defines genocide not only as
killing or causing serious bodily harm,
but also includes quote deliberately
inflicting on a group conditions of life
calculated to bring about its physical
destruction in whole or in part. That is
precisely what the conditions of Omar,
which spells out how dimm are to live
under Islam, did. It imposed negative
conditions of life calculated to
pressure cops to abandon their Christian
identity and embrace Islam in exchange
for relief from persecution and
discrimination. At any rate, Adel
Gindi's achievement in writing a sword
over the Nile goes beyond simply
documenting historic persecution. At the
end of every chapter, he analyzes the
translated material significance. A
comprehensive essay at the book's
conclusion offers a synthesized
overview, including suggestions on how
to move forward on the so-called Coptic
question. Gindi, moreover, does not shy
away from calling out individual cops,
often clerical leaders, for complicity
or acquiescence in their flocks,
suffering. For all these reasons and
more, A sword over the Nile is a
welcome, insignificant book. In one
volume, we now have the largely unknown
historical experiences of Egypt's Coptic
Christians under Islam, drawn from
primary sources that were previously
inaccessible or untransated. This is not
just a window to the past. It is a
warning to the future.